(Transcribed by TurboScribe.ai. Go Unlimited to remove this message.) Okay, let's go.
I'll take AI.
Okay, this is my video.
Okay, it should work.
30 minutes.
Okay, basically, this video is very important, so
it's like, you know, all my stuff, you
know.
Okay, guys, so this video is on biological
informatics.
Oh, it's just taken...
Oh, it's recording now.
Okay, so basically, this video is on biological
informatics, which is like, sustainable information, or student
information, it's a programme for the sort of
an internet, you know, artefact that you can,
you know, but because I'm autistic, ADHD, asperge,
disability, basically, this one is very personal to
me.
It's like, you know, who is an Amity?
This is ontology.
What's my role?
What's my purpose?
What's my task?
You know, I'm going to film a few
videos, but I'm just going to make you
one.
You know, I think it's a language that
everything I'm working on anyway, you know.
If you remember the wheel initiative, like, you
know, the wheel, you're the perfect, you know,
it's basically, oh, my initiatives are with the
axioms.
Like, the wheel, it's like, you know, you
are perfect, you know, but the system is
broken, so you can use those as pounds
from this, and the customer give you a
house, you know, and have the skills with
14.
But you are perfect, you know, that's the
axioms of the initiatives, you know, because, you
know, there are flutes that are not like,
they're not biassed, they're just there, you know,
just things that we do, but through, but
we have to frame them, you know, from
a reference, okay.
So, basically, I'm talking to you guys, if
you're not joining initiatives, but, you know, I
don't really speak to you guys.
Anyway, so, basically, my video here.
So, the first initiative was the wheel.
Now, the other one, I was like, I
did rediscovery.
So, who's me if I seek to cancel
through the 30 million pounds?
I'm not poor anymore.
I wear diamonds, I wear rings, but, you
know, I need to build, and that's what
my business opening represents.
The rebuilding of my personality, myself, solving the
problems that bug me in the past, because
I had to, because I had to enter
the system, you know, I have the system,
I have the brain, because I'm a man,
so 2% has gender freedom, which is
kind of a bioformatics enquiry.
So, basically, my PhD is in ontology, ontological,
the knowing of the self, the mind, who
you are, me, myself, and I, and, like,
you know, building ontological vision, probabilistic systems, I
know what to do, I can act on
what to do, you know, they don't need
to hear.
Now, we have this, too.
Okay, basically, this one is very important for
me.
So, basically, so, if I'm, basically, if the
jargon is in my mind, if I'm talking
to my mind, you know, I see the
jargon in my mind, and I make a
replica of the juggernaut from the world in
my mind, you know, that juggernaut is my,
is my mother through the mind, you know,
how does my mind work with this information?
Because, you know, if the copy of the
juggernaut from the fan fiction is in my
head, and I see the juggernaut, you know,
but it's in my head, you know, am
I still me, you know, I think it's
kind of a problem, you know, because, you
know, I can have, you have all the,
I'm going to read the version, I'm going
to read the version, I see everything in
my head, I almost knew myself and I
in my head, there's no one else there,
just, like, I'm trying to navigate systems that
are, that's kind of, like, imaginative, pictures, see
myself in the pictures, see myself moving about
myself, but, you know, for me, it's like,
you know, I can learn something in my
head, I can practise images in my head,
like, you know, if I want to show
you a basketball, I can do a technique
in basketball, I can check it, like, you
know, if I see, if I see an
image, I see, like, me checking a hoop
to a net, you know, me checking a
basketball to a net, I can do, like,
five times, I can do, I can get
it, like, four times perfect, you know, depending
on the range and distance, but, you know,
because it's not isomorphic to the system, I'm
building out, because, you know, those are some
new ways to learn about the promotion, new
strategies that are very down, like, then we
practise with that imaging, like, you know, like,
you know, image recursion.
So, basically, this information is very important to
you.
So, basically, on my problem with systems, kind
of new divergence and artistic, I'm going to
give you the, this is what I'm doing,
you know, so, basically, this video is for
me to give you guys my view, my
myself, my image stuff, you know, because, you
know, I'm doing my PhD and if I
don't do it, you know, properly, you know,
you guys do not lie on my vision,
then it will all come to trouble.
So, basically, there are, for me, I know
there are four types of main people, the
people that have no perception of what they're
doing, no perceptual membrane, they just have, they
have no bubble, but they have a bubble,
you know, they basically have a bubble around
them, but they have that bubble, and it's
not physical, they can't, it's not like in
their head, it's just they are, but they
are, the bubble is not, keeps them conscious,
they don't know, they don't know where the
bubble, you know, just thinking everything, it's just
action.
So, basically, everything they do, so, if I'm,
if I'm, like, one of them, I would
just try to, I could never see an
image in my head when I try to
do a basketball, because, you know, it's nothing
to see, just practise the basketball, me checking
the ball in the real world and checking
into the hoop or the net.
There we go, or processing on baseball, or
sporting activity, you know, and I get better
by documenting the, in the real world, you
know, there's no, there's no, you know, inner
self to that, outer, there's no, there's no,
like, you know, world I can create in
my head to, like, or instead to connect
with my head to get that thing out
faster, better, or, you know, like, you know,
all my epiphanies are documented in the real
world, there are no bridges, you know, but,
you know, there's lots of roots compared to,
I mean, so, basically, I am a visual
monologue, I'm an inner monologue, but I'm not
this one, you know, my brain wouldn't let
it, like, it hurts my brain, you know,
for some reason.
For me, my senses are, I would say,
the worst senses, because I see everything around
me, everything, but, you know, I see myself,
I feel myself, but I have an inner
self, inner self, my soul, my heart, I
have a bit longing, so, basically, for me,
I think that aliens are, like, certain, like,
genes or something, I don't really know, but
for me, I have a visual monologue, and
all that means to me is, like, you
know, I can practise basketball, or, as I'm
told, I'll have a football in my head,
you know, just go to the ball, like,
blah, and practise some kind of move, you
know, and I can still get that same
performance, or better, you know, because in my
head, I'm compressing the world, I make myself
better, but, you know, the, you know, if
I want something that's better, but, you know,
the real world is just better for me,
because it's, I think, just simulated or emulated,
you know, I just need to just do
it, you know, you know, so I'm saying
that's the kind of legacy, but, you know,
I do get better anyway, I do it,
if I do practise correctly, and I do
it, and you do this on those, or
the football, the rules, you know, this I'm
actively doing, like, writing it down, the comments,
you know, watching the videos, everything, and the
reward, you know, then I can, oh, no,
no, I was continuing from my world, so,
basically, this is a foul, it's a foul,
okay, basically, number one second, let's start a
video now, guys, just one second, guys, and
then try to solve this problem ontologically, so
let me just see what, I can do
it, I'll resume, okay, perfect, I got six
minutes, I thought, fine, okay, okay, okay, basically,
my video started, I got a recording it,
temp, close that, okay, basically, go for video,
so, guys, so, basically, this one's very important
to me, so, basically, guys, this video is
very important to me, I'll just start again,
because, you know, the one, I have to
upload the one, because, you know, there's no
part of this video, but, you know, it
just turned out, it's my space, my system,
anyway, I don't have to worry about it
now, that's what I did, so, basically, this
video is very important to me, it's for
a PhD, basically, you know, it reminds me
of ontology, which is my ontological vision, intelligence
infrastructure, conscious systems, those that are limited to
accident on behalf, and these dimensional game theory,
with open sense metrics, which is like the
sight, touch, feel, taste, and hearing, which is
like the sight senses, and the sixth sense,
they're, like, you know, they're phenomenological, or PRP
sense, like, you know, things they observe from
the world, you know, they act in that
too, so, the AI systems are built in
the, or something, you know, they have to
use that sense, open sense, open access, open
access, which is a bit of open sense
compliance, for, you know, typical people, but it's
really the first, you know, this one is
very important, let me just start by giving
you the take for my recordings, so, basically,
open sense metrics, you go like the IKE
principle, or the inverse kinematics principle, or the
inverse kinematics principle, or the inverse kinematics, you
know, the ears, which are the sensor systems,
which we've been testing, we've been testing, like,
you know, input, and he has to handle
it accordingly, whether it's, like, a, like, you
know, slow down for a person crossing the
road, sensing that person, seeing it through his
lenses, or, like, or, like, or, like, or,
like, or the key principle, like, you know,
kinematics has to slow down, because there's an
object in the way, but you have to
adjust for that, for the person, you know,
it has to take time, when it's a
wall or something, it doesn't really matter, but
it has to slow down, so it doesn't
crash the car, you know, like, a system
that's ontological, he knows what he's doing, he
knows he knows nothing, you start with, and
he barely knows what he's doing, he then
takes a piece of information from the robot,
so, basically, one thing to use, like, you
know, my EI, and she has to use
an EI system, see what he did, see,
what did that mean, to observe, and then
cover from that, based on active senses, system,
you know, observe a consumer, senses that mean
something to the EI, you know, if an
EI system is good for you, you don't
want an EI system to burn your food,
so you want an EI system to be,
like, you know, noise short, you know, basically,
I'm saying that I'm going to get old,
actually, I don't want to get old, I
don't want to get old, I hate it,
you know, basically, I'm just scared of getting
old, you know, trying to preserve myself in
the best way possible, you know, if I
can start using the EI system for me,
I'll do it just to make my life
easier, I'm going to be stressed, you know,
and things like that, you know, I have
my ontological vision home, based on my consciousness,
encoded into it, you know, my care for
my care, you know, I make care for
everyone else, because I'm the best cook, you
know, things like that, that's a safety critical,
like, food, do you want to burn the
food, burn the house, for example, you know,
you must know what he's doing, you know,
it's ontological, it must be knowing what he's
doing and learning from it, we are buyingformatics,
with a score in, like, a score in
a heuristic, okay, it's a short evaluation, okay,
accessibility, okay, so basically, this man called a
marvel juggernaut, so basically, he's a marvel juggernaut,
basically, to marvel juggernaut thing, you know, if
it's unstoppable, you know, but, you know, he's
unstoppable, yes, but, you know, I'm seeing him
in my head, you know, but he's in
my head, you know, basically, he's real, but,
you know, I start seeing him, I start
hallucinating him, but, you know, I don't hallucinate
him, so, I'm seeing him, the juggernaut says
in my head, you know, it's not my
head, you know, but, you know, what does
it mean for a juggernaut to be in
my head and be unstoppable, to be unstoppable,
for, you know, run through anything, it just
gets the momentum going, you run through whatever,
you know, he's having the speed, that's the
thing, it's like, you know, once uniform division,
you're going to have to concentrate, you can
run faster, faster, you can fall faster, faster,
but, you know, once he starts running, you
can't stop him, you know, it's a certain
speed, you know, it's like, you know, you
have to, like, sweetest god, you know, how
are you hacking this god if you mind,
you know, you know, because, you know, that's
going to give him power, you know, and
they say to me, you know, for me,
you know, being a marvel juggernaut in my
head, it's like that, you know, it's like,
if I'm, if I'm going to stop on
my head, you know, and it's not me,
is that thing the new analogy, is that
thing that has to do with my body,
my mind, my soul, you know, because it's
unstoppable force, you know, you know, but it's
like, it's like, you know, it's unstoppable, I
don't really know, it's unstoppable, to the duality
of a unstoppable force, so basically, it's unstoppable,
unmovable, almost unstoppable, basically, he's unstoppable, but unmovable,
so does that mean that, you know, if
this guy is real, and I haven't been
mind controlled to see the juggernaut, and that
mind controls someone else's control of my mind,
because, you know, the juggernaut can control my
mind, because, you know, I think it's real,
you know, but then I have no real,
because, you know, every time I think about
the juggernaut, oh, the juggernaut is here, and
I get control, my mind control, you know,
things like that, it's not me, that's not
me doing it, it's someone else doing it,
but, you know, it's not real to me,
it's real to me, because, you know, I
have been brainwashed to believe it's real, but,
you know, the unstoppable force, I'm the immovable
object, so basically, I'm right now, I'm immovable,
because, you know, I haven't got the juggernaut
in my head, you know, it's like that,
you know, so how does the mind and
body encoder, you know, what does that mean
to be unstoppable, immovable, you know, these are
the unstoppable forces, the immovable objects, what's the
reaction there, what happens there, you know, especially
at the emulation simulation, you know, basically, my
system starts to hallucinate, or like, it starts
to get something, which is, I don't understand,
you know, I don't understand, you know, after
really, that's really the information co-humanity, you
know, because, you know, I don't understand what
I'm saying, you know, actually, what is like
an image of some other olive oil being,
you know, you know, what is, like, you
know, is trying to access other worlds, what's
in the mind, you know, things like that,
I'm no worried about it, I'm just worried
about how the EI interprets it, you know,
interprets the information that I don't understand, that
I've programmed to interpret, you know, but it
doesn't interpret that from I see everything around
me, you know, but, you know, basically, I'm
saying, yeah, there's no hallucination, whenever hallucination is
this scenario, but, you know, if it does
not hallucinate it, then what is that information
that I can classify it, so what's he
trying to classify, you know, what it sees
in his mind, or, you know, what is
cooking, you know, what is doing, what he's
trying to navigate, you know, because it's ontological,
just to know what it sees, just to
navigate it here.
He doesn't know, he just asks me, you
know, because, you know, he may be, but,
you know, I love EI, the way we're
experimenting by itself and doing that kind of
thing, you know, it's our chatbot, and the
EI system is a chatbot, and the chatbot
just, like, doesn't call me back, it's not
ontological, because, you know, I may be depressed
or anything, I may be, you know, I
may be Mars or something, but the EI
system says, oh, you work some, my vision
for this is, like, you know, are you
working more money, you don't call this the
EI for a week, and the EI system
says, hey, are you all right, mate, are
you okay to talk today, are you, are
you okay, you know, my ontology is, like,
you know, it cares for you, it's you,
it's you, it's you, you know, it's like,
you know, it's like in you, you, okay,
what comes to mind, it can be, that's
what I'm saying, you know, what does it
mean for you, in some days to know
yourself enough, and have a relationship with you,
that's, like, the EI system, the EI system
says, yeah, you, because, you know, we have
an oral birth certificate, you know, we have
a UEI, you know, and that EI will
learn from you, you know, it's, you know,
personal account, and personal services, it doesn't need
to, you don't need to see it, you
don't need to see it anymore, it's just
you, it's just you, because, you know, you
know, it's from you, it's just you, if
you don't wanna just turn off, but, you
know, just have the version of turn off,
you need to turn off because when you
enter the window, your oral cell card, you
know, your birth cell card, you know, then
you got this here, basically, my, I'm wondering,
it's because of, you know, this is something
that's unstoppable, am I the only one unstoppable,
you know, it can't be, you know, there's
no, it's not, it's not unstoppable, but then
it's, all the things that are But that
means there's something that there's many things that
are unstoppable, because you know, unstoppable Or it
could mean there's nothing that's unstoppable but you,
because you know, you are the phenomenologist, you
only want to do it, you know Be
unstoppable, because you know, he's the most unstoppable
in this universe, but I'm the immeasurable object
in my universe That's my world, my perception
of him.
So you think, if he tries to run
me over, you know, he will just be
wasting his time, you know, because you know
Actually, he can't stop me, because I'm real,
he's not, you know, that's what I say,
but he's not that intelligent, basically My mind
is like that, so I can imagine all
the stuff in my world, my opportunity can't
effectively affect me, because I don't hallucinate it
I don't make it up.
It's really something I can control and like
control very well So back to it, so
buying so much this relationship title, so we
go, let's talk about this with basically, the
term isotope in my framework, quasi-state, which
is quantum superposition Basically, you go to github
.com such quasi, that's the quantum superposition isotopes,
you know, quasi github.com quasi isotope superposition
isotope, because you know, it's like a based
on quantum system So basically, for every proton
you have, there is a positive recharge, because
positive recharge and it's probably open to positive
recharge, you know But the opposite one is
negatron, that means it's all negatron charge Now,
these two are just put over, you know,
in quantum states, we have like quarks, blue
ones you know, what are these things I
don't understand but they have isotope slayers, you
know, they can be opposites in various, they
do the same thing the same ontology, have
the same ontology, you know, row types, but
you know, there are different models of ontology
and for different ecosystems, like the systems that
you model you know, they are different, because
they are just like a biological sustainable for
different ecosystems but they have the, you know,
alkali-axis principle, you know basically, they have
some kind of encoding that's sustainable for them
you know, because they are in the world
of new physics, different kind of physics or
that process, excuse me, again, all kinds of
different kinds of rules in the universe but
you know, attraction can be different, poor, but
you know, quasi-state is quantum superposition isotope
reposition is, you know, explain the kind of
properties that do the same thing over quantum
principles formally, of course but you know, what
I'm saying is, let's show about the waves,
its energy actually, for example, I can have
a wire of charger, I can send a
wire of signal, coherently and I have the
same thing as an actual current, you know,
that's what I'm saying because I don't have
to like, if I get a wire right
now, I don't have a wire if I
get this wire, this is a wire thing,
and this is a charger but my phone,
I don't charge my phone now, so this
wire here doesn't really work so this wire
here is a charger, it's like a USB
type C charger this one is broken here,
so if I plug this in here, I
shoot the charger here and get it out
there, you know, current, current, current, current, current
going through this wire, but it's not broken,
so I can't use it now on my
phone, but you know, it's like, you know,
it goes through you plug in this little
socket, it goes click, you put it here
in components, then it goes in so this
wire, it has the electrical charge going through
it it comes, basically goes, you can see
the electrical and it actually gets excited, I
get a portable charge and then it leaves
the charge when it becomes negative and it
flows back the other way, because, you know,
there's no way to go unless it's down,
it's got more energy, down the coil and
you can go back, you know, because, you
know, it's a cycle of electricality but this
one, so I can send them the same
representation as a signal, the waveform like, you
know, as a waveform in this digital current,
you know like, as I'm going to go
through the digital system one other system, you
know, the digital wave that has some effect
to the, like, a bit of really discharge
the same thing, but that current is the
same thing as the current the current doesn't,
it's wireless, and this was not wireless it
doesn't break down, actually so what I'm saying
to you, stop looking at me, fucking guy!
STOP LOOK AT ME!
what I'm saying to you, guy, because someone's
dead just look at me in my fucking
car, I said I'm your boyfriend so what
I'm saying to you is like the electrical
current is the same as the as the
electrical wave but, you know, it goes back
the direction so it can be, there can
be many electrical positions if you're using a
current, if you're using a particular biological sustainability,
it doesn't really matter the abusive wave format,
you know as long as that codec, let's
define it as like a a kind of
codec, information, it's the same thing you represent
through the medium the medium is just the
spectrum the medium is just the wire the
current goes into the coil, or the wire
but it will work together as an electrical
system via electrical electric, which is like a
magnetic which is like the north magnetic, you
know the magnetic poles of the world, you
know that create the field, the current field
around the earth or the globe, you know
that's like, you know, stop solar radiation coming
in and out of the world you know,
it goes through, you know because you know,
that's, you have to get into the magnetic
field to attract debris, but you know it
doesn't really cause much, you know so that's
actually top for you you know, for me,
this is like very important because, you know,
if I can show there's an isomer, there's
an isomer across a set of three, try
try a biopattern that, then I've solved my
problem which is like signing biological informatics based
on a pair, basically one pair will be
like using an electric charger and then another
pair will be like a magnetic wave that's
like a natural magnetic wave in the field
in the radio waves, microwaves, infrared visible light,
ultraviolet actually cameras, you can do the same
thing for the waves here, and the WOMO
waves will be like the people, so this
can upload, download, and WOMO consume, observe consumers
you know, pair to pair to pair for
real world heuristic measure for the mind, for
the G for the model, the consciousness in
the model as a topology thing that's possible
that can have a variance, basically this try
that has so I can present the magnetic
spectrum more way, the WOMO system, you can
have the opposite infrared quasi-opposite actually, typically
in a quantum system do it in a
so basically, so I control all the system,
and show that the system does what it
does, without breaking down the whole ecosystem you
know, there's a built-in, you know I
can have it, it's like you know, like
like you know, can't start something I don't
like, even I measure because I'm being like
a sustainable housing infrastructure, you know it reminds
me of the mind and the brain, I
don't know the thing, basically so basically, I'm
going to give you my basketball analogy so
basically, in my mind there's no perception, and
so basically something is in my mind there's
no perception of the network there's no perception
of the talk no ontological look I had
then you know, of pre-emcession and just
the doing of the thoughts that's one person
my, I think my let me check let
me check oh, I got basically, ontology, basically
essentially, there's no some people, basically there's no,
you don't see a football in their head,
you just kick the ball you know, they
don't see the basketball, they don't see the
basketball they're checking their head, on their mind
they just check the basketball that's the difference,
for me, for me some people do the
talks, I tell them they don't have a
pre, I'm not sure what they want to
do some kind of curvature angle they want
to take, some kind of pre-calculation they
want to do, which I call look ahead
calculation you know, the AI must do that
for me, but you know they just do
the talks basically, do I know do I
know what, do I know do I know
ahead of time what I want to do,
before I do it so it's like a
meta-system a meta-cognition system, do I
know what I'm going to do how I'm
going to do it before I do it
do I have enough information to do that
thing effectively which is called the post-demo
cost function which is like a, I know
enough to do a state you know to
act on it but as someone else, basically,
my one is like I have two basically,
I think this is my one is a
visual monologue so I'm in a monologue, a
visual auditory monologue, so basically I see, because
you know when I play basketball I can
calculate a lot of patterns and predict things
ahead of time you know, if I'm in
a flow state and I know whatever is
going on I can get that, I think
it's called three three groups based on the
organisation you know, just by, behind the net
you know, one, three, three pointers you know,
just on the midway line you know, those
are three pointers you can get three pointers
to my team free the hook, because that's
my ontology, that's my known, I really know
what I'm going to do I really predicted
this happening, I really calculated, it's not like
I'm being a visual monologue, I can see
ahead of time, I did act on it
it's kind of powerful actually, because you know
that means I'm in the flow state I
am, I'm working coherently I know how this
system works, you know, whether it's basketball or
like any dribbling, it's a sport you got
the ontology monologue so basically, the ontology monologue
is like for me, I think A, B,
C if he does A, I do C
then I'm going to get the ball at
D which is the A, B, C if
he goes to A, then I go to
B if A, if player A comes to
player 1 comes to me, at B I
go to B, 3 which is like the
third question even then, when he leaves me,
on the centre I go to C, get
to C which is 3 points up, C2
which is 3 points and then shoot, but
that's all words in my head like you
know, and then I find the ball, because
you know, I really calculate that thing, and
I think I just shoot the ball and
I get the 3 points up and I
win the game, or score a point and
the course continues, you know so you know,
it's like I've historically understand the scenario in
real time because I have meta information, I
have a commission already about what's going to
happen, you know because I don't need to
wait to act on my meta condition, my
process my ability to act, you know I
just already have the insight of that state
surreal, in a surreal way we can interpret
phenomenologically lensing the principle as a protocol for
the task we're going to do and that
task is done, you know and then basically,
this thing I'm saying to you is the
way I work, the visual and the auditory,
they can be both at the same time
like normally when the genes are much easier,
but that's in my mind and then I
got the open sense one so basically, oh,
I think my pen is done ok, it's
almost done, basically the open sense matrix 5
senses, sight sight, smell sense touch and sight,
smell sense, touch sight, sense touch
feel, touch sight, smell eyes, nose, mouth or
taste, taste basically, I have to start a
new one now because my auto, yes, finish
I'm going to say wait a bit, ok,
let me just check what I want basically,
yes yes, I've got a sight, smell taste,
touch taste, touch one, two sight my 5
senses you know, what is 5 senses around
me is an IK, my observation of the
IK principles and the K principles my action
on the K which like the first kind
of matter is how it affects me or
like me, even the one doing the touch
and how it affects the other person because
I don't really care about the opponent which
is called the open sense matrix if I'm
playing basketball you know, how I, how I
how I, how I, how I do a
combo the game, because the combo is you
have to see the combo then activate or
have to touch something touch your input or
get some kind of confirmation from the input
and then do the combo and do the
move you know, it's like you know, that's
the observer obviously, this is just like an
observer consumer model, observer user model for the
sight so I can see something and I
can act and that's something I see, I
can smell something and then taste, that's something
you know, it can be like a bi
-pattern that for sensory for AI cooking, but
open sense sensory matrix is about this, like
you know, seamless look-ahead ontology for direct
and biological vision in real time, for UVR
post-life state resolution you know, if there
is a post-life quantum quantum quantum equivalent
for quantum computers such as Hallmark gates for
like signal state, is there something that I
can mirror to compute ahead of time, because
I see, I look before I see you
know, something I can use to tailor this
to myself for that ontological work I'm going
to do VR Philharmonic Lensing as a key
protocol based on the coherent infrastructure ok, guys,
this video, I want you guys to use
this video, I'm just trying to explain to
you me, me only, you know, if you
want to understand what I'm saying to you,
just understand me, and see how we can
understand other people if you want to go
there but, you know, I want you guys
to try to, like, be honest to me
and see what you guys can do, ok
guys, thank you very much, I'm going to
try to share this video now, thank you
very much thank you very much for my
thing oh, thank you very much, done and
this one's done well, this one should be
done now, and I'll stop this one now,
I'm gone